GET A LOAD FROM DISK -- OF THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S POLL NUMBERS
HAVE DROPPED.
WHAT IS HIS PLAN TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE BECAUSE OF HOW HE WILL
TRUST HIS OPINION ON THIS IS THE
QUESTION PEOPLE ARE FOLLOWING
WITH THE HEALTH GUIDELINES.
>> WE THINK IT IS A REFLECTION
OF PEOPLE BEING SICK AND TIRED
OF COVID AND SOME OF THAT IS A
REDUCTION OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED BEING FRUSTRATED THAT
THERE'S STILL THE PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULATION WHO ARE NOT
VACCINATED.
AND THAT IS IMPACTING THEIR
DAILY LIVES.
>> THEY BLAME EVERYTHING ON
COVID.
INFLATION, AFGHANISTAN,
LOCKDOWNS.
>> IT IS NOT THE DELTA VARIANT,
ACTUALLY.
IT IS NOT JOE BIDEN STANDING IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
VILIFYING THE UNVACCINATED AND
TELLING THAT VACCINATED YOU HAVE
EVERY RIGHT TO BE ANGRY WITH THE
UNVACCINATED WHEN -- IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED.
YOU ARE OKAY.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE ANGRY AND
THE UNVACCINATED.
OKAY IT WAS HUNTER'S DADDY
TELLING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HOW
TO RAISE THEIR KIDS.
AND THE SAME TIME?
YOU HAVE AN ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION CONTESTED TO
REALITY AND WENT THEY ARE
COCKING THAT
SITUATION, THEIR GOT IS TO LIKE
ABOUT AFGHANISTAN OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, AL QAEDA, OH,
AMERICANS CAN GET AIRPORT IF
THEY WANT OUR ALLIES ARE WITH
HAS BECOME MUCH MORE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE TO
TOLERATE?
WHEN A THREE RUG GETS CAUGHT
WITH HIS HEAD IN DEPTH, WIDTH
AND HE LIES ABOUT IT, THAT IS.
BUT NOT THIS OLD COOT CUTLINE
OVER AND OVER TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
STOP ACTING LIKE WE ARE STUPID.
>> YOU GOT TO STOP HOLDING BACK.
YOU GOT TO LET US KNOW HOW YOU
FEEL.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON HERE.
CONTRACTED NUMBERS.
AFTER AFGHANISTAN, HIS NUMBERS
WENT DOWN.
CLEARLY NOT OF COVID.
>> NO.
IT IS A FULL BREATH OF ISSUES.
MARTHA MENTIONED THE IMPACT OF
COMPLETION.
80% OF THE COUNTRY IS CONCERNED
ABOUT IT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS LAST WEEK
AND I MENTIONED THAT WHAT I
WOULD DO IS ACTUALLY OWN
FLIPPING POLL NUMBERS BY SAYING
I TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THESE
DECISIONS.
I THINK THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
BETTER OFF.
THIS IS A ROUGH PERIOD.
I AM SOMEONE WHO LISTENS TO THE
PUBLIC AND I'M GOING TO GO BACK
AND I'M.LOOK AT MY POLICY.
AND JOE BIDEN WON A HUGE PRIMARY
BECAUSE HE WAS THE POINT I.
HE WAS THE GUY WHO SAID, THEY
DON'T WANT FREE HEALTHCARE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT DOCUMENTED.
THAT REALLY SET HIM APART.
AT THAT OPPORTUNITY, THERE'S
SOMETHING IN IT MORE IMPORTANT,
WHICH I THINK IS THE TRUST
ISSUE.
I THINK THIS IS WHY BIDEN WON
THE GENERAL ELECTION.
HE WAS TESTED MORE TO HANDLE
THIS.
AND NOW THERE'S NO TRUST THE CDC
PDF KEEP WORKING BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AT THE SAME
LEVEL.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT IS REALLY
HURTING HIM.
>> WHEN IS HE GOING TO
HALF-STAFF MOMENT LIKE BILL
CLINTON HAD?
THE COUNTRY DID NOT VOTE FOR A
LEADING LEFTIST.
>> YOU MAY HAVE TO THE SHIV
BERNIE AT SOME BACK.
BUT --
>> THEY WILL LET HIM SHOW UP
WITH A TOOTHBRUSH.
>> MAYBE SEND, WENT TO THE FACE.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT WAS IMMIGRATION IN
AFGHANISTAN THAT DROVE HIS
NUMBERS DOWN.
THEY WERE IN THE 30s THERE.
IT WAS THE IMAGES THAT PEOPLE,
FORGET ABOUT THREE PARTS THE
ECONOMY, INFLATION.
THAT IS THE LABOR SHORTAGE.
HIS COVID NUMBERS HAVE
DETERIORATED.
SO HE PLACES A TEST
FOURTH-QUARTER NOW BECAUSE DELTA
COULD GO UP.
RIGHT NOW, DELTA IS GOING DOWN.
THAT WE HAD HAS HIT IS GOING
DOWN.
THAT IS GOOD NEWS.
BUT IF YOU COULD PUT A WIN ON
THE BORDER WITH THESE TWO
SPENDING BILLS HE IS DOING AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE, THAT COULD
GIVE HIM A LITTLE OF SPACE
MOMENTUM.
THIS IS A WEAK WHAT DID GOD.
NO POLITICAL CAPITAL.
INDEPENDENCE DON'T WANT TO TOUCH
THE SKY.
NOT A CHANCE.
>> I WOULD AGREE WITH JEN PSAKI
TO A CERTAIN EXTENT.
NOBODY ACCESS TO THAT DELTA WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN.
I THINK ANYBODY WHO IS PRESIDENT
WOULD HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
WEAKNESS BASED ON THAT NUMBER.
WHEN WE DID THE FOX POPE, THE
LARGEST AMOUNT OF PEOPLE'S
REASONS, 22% I THINK WAS THAT
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT HIS
CONFIDENCE.
THAT IS BIG.
AND THEN WAS AFGHANISTAN, I
BELIEVE THAT NEXT IN MY.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN BLAME ANOTHER WAVE OF COVID.
THAT IS A SERIOUS CONCERN THAT
ALMOST A QUARTER OF THE PEOPLE
--
>> YEAH.
PRE-EXISTING NOTION.
AND IF